once again we have three statements here
and your goal is to figure out which of
these statements are true and it might
be more than one of them and i'll give
you a little bit of time to do it
all right let's go through each of these
one by one so the first one right over
here an object moving to the left so
let's draw some object and it's moving
to the left so those are it's moving in
that direction right over there
must
must have a leftward force acting on it
so it doesn't have to have
a force that is
that is acting on it towards the left
and we didn't even talk about net force
or or balanced force or unbalanced force
it's saying it must have a leftward
force acting on it well we know from
newton's first law that if this object
is moving at a constant velocity it's
moving at a constant velocity to the
left there doesn't need to have any
forces acting on in fact if no forces
act on it or if there's no unbalanced
forces acting or no forces at all it
will just continue to move to the left
so an object moving to the left does not
have to have a leftward force acting on
it if there was an unbalanced
net or if there's a net leftward force
acting on it it would accelerate towards
the left but you don't have to have one
if it already has some velocity in the
left direction it can just keep going
there without any forces at all so this
is not true you don't have to have a
leftward force acting on it
second statement a tennis ball is thrown
upward by a boy on earth so let's say
that this is the tennis ball so let me
draw this is the tennis ball it's just
left it's just left the boy's hands
it's thrown upwards so the tennis ball
once again it's it's going in the
upwards direction just like that once
the ball has just left the boy's hand
and is traveling upwards so this is the
situation that we're talking about the
net force on the ball is also upwards
so let's think a little bit about all of
the forces that are on the ball
this ball right here it's near the
surface of the earth is going to have
the force of gravity acting on it or the
force of earth's gravity pulling on it
so you're going to have the force of
gravity
you're going to have the force of
gravity pulling down on it and is there
going to be anything is there going to
be anything that is is that going in the
other way and we could we could you know
we can think about something like air
resistance but let's just assume that
that's negligible especially
relative to the force of gravity
pulling down on the ball and so we see
here the only major force here
especially if we ignore air resistance
for now and air resistance is also going
to be going in the direction opposite
the ball so it'll really just also go in
the downward direction because the ball
is going to be bumping into things
bumping into things in that and as it as
it moves upwards so we see all of the
net forces on the ball are actually all
the forces on the ball or all the major
forces on the ball that we're talking
about are actually in the downward
direction and that's why remember forces
aren't they're not directly impacting
they are impacting velocity but f equals
m a
f equals m a when you have a net force
in a given direction it accelerates in
that direction so here we have a net
force in the downwards direction it's
going to accelerate the ball downwards
or another way to think about it if the
ball is already moving upwards it's
going to decelerate the ball which is
exactly what we know in everyday life
experience you throw a ball in the air
it is moving upwards right when you when
you throw it right when it leaves your
hand but it's going to slow down slow
down slow down come to a come to a stop
and then start falling again and the
whole time it is being accelerated
downwards or while it's going upwards
you could say it's being decelerated in
the upwards direction so this over here
is also false the net force on the ball
is actually downwards
third statement
a sled is traveling to the left and
slowing down so let's draw this sled so
maybe the sled looks something like this
a sled is traveling
so it's traveling to the left and it's
slowing down so it's decelerating in the
leftwards direction
the net force on that sled must be
directed to the right
this is absolutely true the net force if
the net force here is acted to the right
then the acceleration will also be acted
to the right and if you're moving to the
left and your acceleration is to the
right you are going to be decelerated or
you are going to be you are going to
slow down in your leftward direction so
the only statement that was true here
was statement three